à très peu d'internautes cette édition
2015 du festival de cannes marque une
grande première cette année le président
du jury des longs métrages en
compétition officielle
eh bien il va avoir de tête n'était
jamais arrivé et non chers amis le
président n'est pas un obscur cinéaste
expérimental originaire de tchernobyl
le président est double étant donné
qu'il s'agit des frères coen
spontanément ça a l'air de faire sens
les cônes font partie de ces cinéastes
qui ont toujours eu un rapport très
étroit avec le festival de cannes dans
cet univers ils font partie des
inamovibles des omniprésents de ceux qui
ont probablement des petits fours et un
lit à baldaquin alors non juste au
dessus de la salle lumière au même titre
que pedro almodovar ken loach ou lars
von trier à banon lui plus maintenant on
se des longs métrages des coen ont été
sélectionnés au cours de l'histoire
cannoise et parmi eux huit en
compétition officielle
barton fink le grand saut fargo
o'brother the barber ladykillers no
country for old men et inside llewyn
davis 8 n'entendez-vous c'est déjà
beaucoup mais en plus les grenat ont
bien souvent raflé la mise puisque ils
remportèrent trois fois le prix de la
mise en scène pour barton fink en 1991
fargo en 1996 et veut barber en 2001 une
fois le grand prix du jury pour inside
llewyn davis en 2013 et surtout surtout
la fameuse palme d'or en 1991 pour
barton fink bimbo l'exposé sur la table
merci bonsoir tout ça fait 2 les
présidents de jury cannois les plus
récompensées par le festival
la manifestation s'est choyer ses
chouchous super choisir ça mais la
présidence deux frères coen n'est pas
une simple reconnaissance
elle a une valeur hautement symbolique
en effet cette 68e édition cannoise va
aussi permettre au festival de célébrer
les 120 ans de l'invention du
cinématographe par les frères lumière
auguste et louis de leur petit prénom et
la mise en avant des coen symbolise donc
cette dualité qui est à la base du
cinéma tel qu'on le connaît aujourd'hui
et vous allez me dire des frères qui ont
une histoire d'amour suivi avec cannes
et il y en a pas mal d'autres comme les
dardenne qui ont eu la palme d'or en
1999 et 2005
l'état via ni qu'ils ont remportée en
1977 ou encore les watch hrw qui a
maintenant un peu plus maintenant
et en dehors des plus récompensés on a
aussi les frères yoox dans le premier
film menace ii society émergé lors de
l'édition 1993 du festival les frères
larrieu qui furent sélectionnés avec le
voyage aux pyrénées en 2008 ou encore
les phares pong qui clôturèrent un
certain regard en 2006 en donnant dans
le fantastique avec recycl et je vais
m'arrêter là parce que si on commence à
s'aventurer chez les frères qui n'ont
pas forcément d'histoire avec canne en
main jusqu'à 2022 en flux tendu alors
pourquoi choisir spécifiquement les coen
pour représenter cette dualité des
origines
je vous le demande parce que tout
simplement les coen c'est le big boss
final de la dualité fraternelle la
dualité ultime extrême pimpante en
diable qui pétaradent à tout va et cette
dualité elle se trouve sur trois fronts
tout d'abord dans le processus de
création lui-même
en effet les deux frères produisent
leurs propres films écrivent leur
scénario à 80 et s'occupe d'eux mêmes du
montage
ce qui est assez rare à hollywood pour
être mentionné autant qu'ils le font
sous le pseudonyme de warwick james
steel et les coen c'est donc une
application totale est bicéphale à tous
les postes clés une démarche double qui
se ressent forcément dans l'identité
profonde de leur film et même si pendant
longtemps joué elle a été créditée à la
réalisation tandis qu'athènes était à la
production ces étiquettes était de leur
propre aveu une pure surface puisque la
segmentation des rôles est bien plus
floue et variable en coulisses
d'ailleurs depuis 2004 à la sortie de
lady killer est années maintenant
créditée à la coréalisation ensuite la
dualité chez les coen se retrouve aussi
dans la réception de leurs oeuvres
les bougres ont réussi une prouesse peu
commune développer une véritable
démarche d'auteur indépendant originaux
et exigeant tout en connaissant un
succès retentissant auprès du grand
public donc la frontière traditionnelle
et stéréotypé entre l'art et celle
populaire l'écho à nice la boulette
chaque matin au petit déjeuner sur du
pain complet
enfin la dualité chez les frangins
s'exprime dans le contenu même de leur
film quand on fait face à leur
filmographie on a vraiment affaire à
deux pôles distincts
d'un côté on a des comédies déjantées et
potache à la the big lebowski aux
arizona junior et de l'autre on a des
films sombres et grinçant à l'atmosphère
lancinante presque irréel là je pense
plutôt à des métrages comme fargo ou de
barber le cinéma des coen hier donc
entre un humour barré et des thématiques
résolument tendue du slip mais à aucun
moment leur filmographie ne tombe dans
l'exercice de style vainement
schizophrène le style cohen reste à
chaque oeuvre
reconnaissable entre mille avec ce
rapport constant au décalage des
situations à l'absurdité du quotidien et
à la figure omniprésente du marginal
doux rêveur l'hydre a beau avoir de tête
son identité reste donc unique et forte
ce biais beau n'ayons pas peur des mots
résultat les frères ont catapulté
président cette année
sur le papier ça va de soi échange est
même méchamment et de les faire qu'est
ce que ça implique réellement on ne peut
généralement observé que la surface d'un
partenariat créatif savoir le résultat
final et pour peu que ce partenariat
soit réussi et s'étendent dans la durée
comme chez les coen
c'est avant tout l'homogénéité qu'on
aperçoit mais c'est sous-estimer toute
la richesse du processus créatif en
amont que ce soit dans les moments
d'harmonie mais aussi de doutes de
diversité ou même de désaccord l'édition
2015 de cannes renforce l'image qu'on se
fait habituellement des frères coen
celle du
entité indivisible mais est ce que ce
n'est pas quelque part une négation de
leur individualité leur voix va qu'elle
comptait quadruple le président du jury
at il le droit de ne pas être d'accord
avec lui même
ont-ils open bar sur la consommation de
russes blancs tant de questions tant de
suspense perlant sur nos faciès à
l'incrédulité soucieuse du sort est
intéressant que cette année le festival
nous donne un aperçu des individualités
au sein du duo de la réalité complexe
qui se trouve derrière une osmose
créatif fantasmer comme idéal l'enjeu
réellement passionnant à mon sens il se
trouve là à travers le cas des co
heineken cup et 2015 pourrait donc nous
proposer une plongée réel dans ce cas un
partenariat créatif au sens large
parce que finalement qu'est ce que le
cinéma si ce n'est cette tension
complexe mais fascinante entre
l'individu et le collectif
la symbolique n'est pas une fin en soi
c'est avant tout un point de départ
j'espère donc que le symbole qu elles
nous permettent cette année de nous
aventurer sur des rivages inattendue